Thunder Commission so loggin and hot
spots after graduation infant in space
on my Malaga Maria in Nam the status I
had a hit so I asked the SWAT coming
stand up when you suppose attendant
honorable members of the Parliament the
situation in the hot spots on the Greek
islands is extremely difficult according
to this week's integrated situation
awareness analyzes report over 47,000
migrants have arrived by sea to the
Greek islands this year this means there
has been a 69 percent increase in
arrival spicy almost 36 thousand persons
are present on the islands inside and
many also outside of vessel camp areas
designed for a maximum of around 8,000
this is the first time we have raised
such a high number since the
implementation of a new turkey statement
conditions are unacceptable migrants and
asylum seekers are facing a dire
situation with significant storages of
basic shelter and unsanitary and
hygienic conditions at risk groups such
as people with disabilities are often
under babe babe unable to access basic
services such as water sanitation and
hygiene facilities unaccompanied minors
are accommodated in facilities which are
not adapted to their needs there are
long lines for pure quality blood
mismanagement
and lack of information which all
contribute to a chaotic and volatile
atmosphere since the end of August there
have been three deaths in and around the
mur
in September they were more than 1,000
unaccompanied minors in Moorea most of
them are living in unsuitable conditions
with adults president honourable members
urgent action is needed and there are
things that can be done quite speedily
such as decongestant the islands which
is also the priority of the Greek
government I understand that there are
plans to transfer over 5,000 asylum
seekers already authorized to continue
the asylum procedure on the mainland to
fast-track these plans would be helpful
we also take note of government measures
to speed up and tighten Asylum
procedures and manage flows decreased by
improving border surveillance more
observation posts are being put up at
the land borders surveillance of the
Everest river is being stepped up while
at the sea borders the capacity of the
Hebert Harbor police will be boosted by
providing additional vessels and
personal many more employees are being
recruited to the asylum service in this
way the ability to handle cases will be
tripled these and other measures are
part of the new ambitious asylum
legislation that the Greek parliament
adopted on 31st of October it will be of
utmost importance to implement as fast
as possible the new provisions including
the asylum and return procedures on
asylum there is reportedly a backlog of
68,000 cases with the new rules in place
asylum requests would be handled within
60 days this is a very welcome
development provided that all required
legal safeguards under the EU law are
also in place the return rate so far has
been critically low for far too long
returns are instrumental in
keeping the numbers down on the islands
the plan of the Greek government
includes a target of returning 10,000
migrants by the end of 2020
this is ambitious but it can be done
with the appropriate procedures in place
and assistance from International
Organization for Migration frontex and
EU member states these measures go hand
in hand with the legislative amendment
amendments on asylum and are all
recognized disease to reduce the
overcrowding of the camps effective
returns are also also required the
cooperation of Turkey it is vital that
both parties apply in good faith all the
provisions and operating procedures
agreed as a result of the statement it
is difficult to predict if arrivals will
continue in line with their current
trends depending on the situation in
Turkey the extended deadline to arrange
for legal papers expired on 31st of
October and the situation along the
turkey Syria and Turkey Iranian borders
the current pressure may be maintained
for some more weeks regardless of the
way the situation develops in Turkey and
the region the urgent steps described
above must be taken immediately to
reduce overcrowding and ensure dignified
conditions for all people in the camps I
am certain that the Commission in its
statement will elaborate on the
assistance and advice it provides to the
Greek government on this issue thank you
very much Madam President I feel
Minister Farrakhan misión I heard his
father commissar have a mobiles thank
you
well dear colleagues as you all know
Greece has been exposed to migratory
pressure for many years now while there
is no comparison with the intensity of
the situation five years ago definitely
were not worth the time we all recognize
the huge challenge that Greece is facing
and that Greece is constantly exposed to
magnitude pressures which at periods
becomes difficult to bear at the
beginning of the year 2019 there were
more than 35 thousand migrants present
on the hotspot Islands 17,000 migrants
were present on lesbos alone it has been
and it is it remains a priority of this
commission to help the entire country
addressing these challenges urgent
action is needed to alleviate the
pressure on the islands and to improve
the conditions for migrants and refugees
we need to do everything we can to
support national authorities and we do
it as regards now the financial support
the Commission has made available to
Greece 2.2 billion euros since 2015 the
largest financial support ever provided
to a Member State for migration we have
also been providing technical and
operational support with colleagues from
the Commission being deployed on the
ground and being in regular contact with
the Greek authorities she's been doing
that too the last five years supporting
the previous government and the current
government in reach that they are doing
whatever they can not address this issue
however and as you know
the role of the national authorities in
handling the situation on the ground
remains of paramount importance I want
to be very clear that the Commission can
only provide support it cannot replace
the Greek authorities the Commission at
all levels operation but equally
politically his permanent parent
contacts with the Greek authorities at
the beginning of October I visited both
Athens and Ankara together with the
Minister of Interior of Germany mr.
Jehovah to discuss the situation with
the government in both countries and
find ways to address the challenges also
in the context of the EU 30 statement in
addition just a few weeks ago a
technical mission at the highest level
with my director general mrs. DVB who
also went to Greece to discuss ways to
further support Greece in developing
effective solutions to the challenges on
the ground in fact many of the existing
problems have become worse with the
increases of arrivals to the islands
over the last six months the D
congestion of the islands and they need
to increase the reception capacity on
the islands and on the mainland remain a
key priority more efficient as Island
procedures would greatly contribute to
improving the processing of the asylum
requests this would also help speeding
up the return of those who have no right
to stay moreover ensuring the provision
of adequate health care and in
particular intensifying the preparations
for winterization
remain paramount and very urgent seeing
those images of vulnerable people
strategy the cold in the past has been a
collective shame for Europe we simply
cannot have another who entered like
that and we have been given all
occurrences from the Greek government
that they have taken care of it
as you all know the Greek parliament has
adopted a new law on a xylem and
reception on the 31st of October with a
goal with the objective of making
procedures more efficient without
compromising on fundamental rights it's
a very important step forward we have
been following closing its adoption
process once it will be formally
notified to the Commission we will
assess the laws compliance with the EU
legal framework now let me give you some
examples obvious support on the islands
the creation of a new reception and
identification centre in Samos in the
island of Samos which Greece is
currently working to implement with EU
funding is a positive step towards
improving the living conditions in the
island it is important to make the new
center operational as soon as possible
and no later than January 2010 the
Commission staff on the island of lesbos
has facilitated with the agreement of
the authorities the renting of an area
where asylum seekers have improved
living conditions in September 2019 the
Commission provided an additional 4.2
million euro funding to the
International Organization for Migration
for the creation of safe zones on all
spot islands the critical situation of
unaccompanied minors in Greece continues
being a top priority and I have
personally called for a product approach
to find new places and reach tangible
results as well as to facilitate their
integration in this context the
Commission has recently award an
emergency assistance project for the
creation of safe zones dedicated for
unaccompanied minors in the islands of
lesbos Samos letters and Kosh
I know that the Minister of Interior of
Greece has also urged his counterparts
to relocate unaccompanied minors
everybody should be part of this effort
it is not a big problem
it is not a neighborhood problem it is a
European problem the Commission supports
Shutts bilateral agreements between
member states including financially the
assistance of member states on the basis
of solidarity and responsibility is of
utmost importance migration remains an
issue of joint responsibility of all
Member States and the Union as a whole
aggression management migration is
testing every day the values and the
principles upon which Europe is built as
I said before it is a European issue and
even an issue of global damages the
moment were discussing this is today
here in Brussels more than 400 million
people are somewhere the world seeking
for a safe haven migrants erectus and
the root causes are still there
and unfortunately they will be there for
many many years so we have a huge
possible
there's this issue and lead the whole
world in providing support to these
people and finding practical solutions
at the same time returns you need to be
accelerated also in the context of the
effective implementation of the
eu-turkey statement the pace the written
all returns from Greece to Turkey
remains critically slow with about 1900
returns since March 2016 of which some
130 in the year 2019 the number is very
low and we all know this low level of
returns is a huge obstacle to any
problems at the same time also in the
field in the area of returns Greece is
and will not be left alone while a lot
has to do with improved procedures by
the Greek authorities the European
borders and Coastguard Agency stands
ready to provide operational and
financial support to Greece for
returning people not only to Turkey
under the EU third statement but to
their country of origin in full respect
I repeated the stresses in full respect
of the principle of Noora Philemon and
other safeguards embedded in our EU a
key on return we acknowledge the efforts
of Greece all these years in all these
interconnected areas a lot has been
achieved but there is still much to be
done the Commission is committed to
continuing working hand-in-hand with the
Greek authorities and together with our
agencies on the ground
mobilize all
port needed there finally let me
conclude again by recalling that only
together in a spirit of trust and unity
we can find sustainable solutions for
the big issue of migration in Europe I
welcome the declaration by the president
in light of last week when she announced
that a draft proposal for a new
migration packets will be presented by
the new commission in the first second
quarter of next year
it must indeed be our goal to become a
model of how migration can be managed
sustainably with a human approach but
effectively and believe me our
Commission has put strong basis for that
thank you very much for attention
unanimous on
[Applause]